[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum heutigen video
leute februar ihr wisst bescheid jeden
verdammten tag kommt ein video und auch
heute natürlich wieder einen iran hält
für hoffnung dass ich habe heute etwas
gesehen auf instagram ich kriegen
manchmal so meine inspirationen für
videos in denen ich einfach sehe ich im
internet nicht um coole sachen sehe und
da habe ich da viel gesehen aber so vor
wir sind näher anschauen schauen wir
erstmal die amazon produktseite an
beides lustig und zwar auf instrument so
ein video gesehen da wurde so eine haben
zusammen in ein wasserglas
reingeschüttet und das hat sich so gar
nicht komisch verhalten unter wasser
na ja nicht raus brot und zwar immer
noch trocken das ist dann weitermachen
und dann habe ich jetzt mal versucht so
wasserabweisend amüsant und bin noch
diese produktseite hier gekommen da hab
ich mal runter gespielt und bin bei der
beschreibung angelangt es ist unmöglich
wie kann etwas eintauchen in wasser
tropfen bleibt wenn der sand nass das
resultat ist eine glucke veraltet
perfekt würde aber unsere menschliche
vor mixen sie genauso aus wie normale
sand aber es hat in der tat mit einem
silizium darf beschichtet waffe abhören
kann diese spezielle beschichtung der
insel trocken übrigens auch nach vier
jahren eintauchen in ein
eltern mit wasser guten bauen oder jeder
anderen struktur die sie zb unter wasser
dann geben sie einfach was aber wenn sie
fertig und ist der dann auch noch
trocken leute es klingt wirklich zu gut
um wahr zu sein
nein keine ahnung was das mit dieser
beschreibung auf sich hat die ist
wahrscheinlich in china geschrieben und
sah also automatisch übersetzt oder so
dass auf jeden fall habe ich diesen sand
ihren stellt auch gut zu wissen in
dieser tollen produktbeschreibung steht
produktgewicht inklusive verpackung 3
199 gramm gucken wir mal auch die
verpackung 33 mal 25 gramm halb fertig
sein 325 kurznachrichten 399 er passt
also packen wir diese kleine packung aus
ich dachte wie gesagt das wäre deutlich
mehr und da ist auch schon der sand drin
also einfach so minütchen ich hatte
nämlich schon irgendwie ein bisschen
günstig so 98 400 m vor dem sand aber
dann ist der preis natürlich noch mal
ein anderer und ich muss sagen wenn ich
das jetzt so in der endphase also
logischerweise der boden aber ansonsten
sieht das eigentlich aus wie ganz
normale sand nah an sich ist ja nichts
besonderes dass ich fehler mache ich
jeden behälter geben und dann werden wir
einfach mal eine packung von saanen und
den hineinschütten wette fahren sollen
fast 10.000 bei für über 10.000 white
berliner und 10.000 euro
ich würde sagen
ich versuche es mal mit dem liedern zu
er ich bin echt ein bisschen gespannt
weil auf instagram sah das so cool aus
die dieser seite unter wasser gegangen
ist und einfach ja der wurde wie zuvor
um irgendwie was essen und 321 o mein
gott
alter schwede
das ist so cool aus alter hettich ist
genau wie in dem video das ich gesehen
habe weiß sieht so aus dass weiter so
mit silber oder sowas nicht erzogen weil
ich nicht pusht das hier auch nochmal
runter was oben drauf ist alter also wie
schon wirklich interessant aus aber was
jetzt wirklich entscheidend ist wenn ich
den sand wieder hoch wurde soll er
angeblich trocken bleiben obwohl er
jetzt gerade unter wasser ist also warum
sehe ich dich oder ich würde sagen wir
testen es einfach mal ich hatte schon
ein löffel an staat und wenn ich das
probiere diesen sand daraus sowohl auf
dem löffel vorerst es ist so komisch
wieder sich sowieso knete irgendwie so
ein bisschen wahrscheinlich war der sand
sich halt nicht mit dem wasser verbindet
das verhält also desto ganz eigenartig
oh mein gott leute hat ist schon gesehen
wohl jetzt den löffel sein draußen so 32
j
und wenn man wieder rein schüttelt alter
schwede das ist ja zu krank also löffel
sand wir wollen raus jetzt wieder
staubtrocken alter das ist wirklich wird
es ist ganz komisch sollte nicht so sein
sollte nicht trocken bleiben wenn er
darauf ist jetzt liegt da oben drauf
eine wasser perle der zweite für den
nächsten versuch nehmen wir uns jetzt
einfach mal einlädt
und schütten uns darauf diese wasser
abweisenden sand und probieren jetzt ein
kügelchen wasser darauf zu balancieren
das ist natürlich alles geplant was er
sät 321 hitze lustig kann was mit
flügelchen was da auf einem löffel
rumspielen djerba vor man würde den
gesamten strand mit diesem wasser
abweisen im sand aufschütten so weit
kommen dass er für als staubtrocken
dieser letzte das ist wie wenn ihr eine
milliarde schafft dann machen zu einem
strandkorb histogramm einem instrument
name ist manchmal da gibt es echt coole
fotos
ich will sagen würde wir schicken jetzt
einfach mal den grünen seine zum wie
lange sein reiter gucken wie sich das
ganze verhält darauf machen einfach
alles also der rest vom grünen seien
kommt auch dazu wie sich dazu auf türen
er ist sind cool was geht vor und ich
bin mir machen
lasst uns das machen worauf wir
wahrscheinlich alle wartet ich werde
diesen sand unter wasser zu verwischen
zu einer großen farm zu einer großen
fahren das habe ich schon immer machen
jetzt einfach alter das ist sowas ist so
geil irgendwie sieht auch irgendwie so
ein bisschen länger aus aber auch ein
bisschen nach scheiße
weißt du nicht auch nicht essen will und
das coolste natürlich wenn jetzt raus
holen
oh mein gott das ist so cool 21 was
macht mein leben
der song ist aber trocken ich werde das
ungeziefer suchen und daraus ein haupt
war dazu in der lage bin teppich
so sehen halt häuser aus magischen sand
dort kann man das auch so cool wenn man
so an der grenze sich sehr hoch und
werde jetzt zum schluss immer probieren
das mit meinen händen einfach anzupassen
und euch zu beschreiben wie sich das
anfühlt sich deine fragen hilft das
irgendwie lustig aber es fühlt sich an
wie ganz ganz normaler sand was ist so
kraft stehende dafür dass das so
funktioniert muss doch wirklich jedes
einzelne sand konnte imprägniert sein
oder und dann kann man einfach reingehen
dann hat mich wieder so sand an seinen
fingern ich würde sagen wir haben alles
gemacht was man machen kann er unter
wasser nicht nass wird es ist absolut
unnötig aber irgendwie cool anzusehen
und vielleicht habt ihr ein bisschen
spaß gehabt aber das video anzuschauen
voll beladen sauber gemacht jetzt würde
ich sagen abonniert auf jeden fall
diesen kanal dass wir im februar im
video februar gerade viel attraktiver im
zweiten video februar kein video
verpasst check auch meine social media
platz kochen wir sehen uns beim nächsten
mal wieder schön dass ich glaube nach
vortag
[Musik]